ما يقرب من التريليون دولار فاتوره اضطرت
اوروبا على دفعها للتخلي عن اعتمادها على
الطاقه الروسيه مبلغ ضخم وقابل للزياده كل
هذه الاموال التي صرفت كان يمكن لاوروبا
ان تستثمرها في امور اخرى كان بامكان
التكاثر الاوروبي استثمار 400 مليار دولار
للردي على قانوني خفض تضخم الامريكي الذي
يمنح مثلا اعفاءات ضريبيه للمكونات
المستخدمه في تقنيات الطاقه المتجدده مثل
السيارات الكهربائيه بشرط ان تكون مصنوعه
في امريكا الشماليه الرقائق الالكترونيه
قصه اخرى اليوم تبلغ حصه اوروبا من انتاج
الرقائق ثمانيه في المئه انخفاضا من اربعه
24 في المئه عام 2000 وفي فبراير 2022
استثمر بروكسل 43 مليار يورو لتطويل قطاع
رقائق الذكيه
ولا الاتحاد الاوروبي ومنافسات العمالقه
كوشنطن بكين وتايوان استكمال كان من
الممكن ان يكون اكبر بكثير لزياده حظوظ
بروكسيل التنفسيه في صناعه الرقائق
العالميه مما تمثله من اهميه قطاعات عده
هناك دول اوروبيه ضمن قائمه الحكومات
الاعلى ديوننا في العام خلال 2022 فرنسا
بقيمه ثلاثه ريليونان و300 مليار دولار
ايطاليا بقيمه 300 مليار ثم مثلها تقريبا
المانيا بقيمه ثلاثه مليونات دولار اذا
تريليون دولار كان من الممكن ان تساهم في
حفظ الدين على ايا من الدول الثلاثه او
كلها بالتساوي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]